I got a request from a friend of mine
Steve from California who was our
Michael Jordan our high school now runs
a very very successful transportation
company by the way on a side note Steve
Talon we are thrilled to hear the great
news about Utah lean very very exciting
can't wait our dinner with you guys and
celebrate when you guys come out here
anyways let me get right into it Steve
sir Pat I want to talk about I'd like
you to do a video on how to start a
project and how to finish a project you
know a lot of us as entrepreneurs we
have ideas or what about we do this
whatever we do that whatever we do this
when we come up with projects and either
then we spend money on halfway we put
200 hours or 40 hours and nothing gets
done and then we're a rating we're
frustrated so what do we do to
systematize for getting projects done
and I'm going to try to do my best to
explain it in a way that helps you get
better at project management first of
all keep a couple things in mind when
you think about projects rule number one
to keep in mind is 90% of projects that
we come up with they're worthless and
you need to be able to how do I describe
this is detach yourself from the project
or the idea and not take it personal
because not all great ideas and projects
are worth your putting a lot of time
into it it's just something you got to
keep in mind now there's nothing wrong
with constant coming up with ideas you
want the machine to be working we also
got to understand that not everything is
going to be the next big thing that you
come up with and you don't need all of
them you got to realize that typically
you know you hear when people say well
you know just didn't work I tried this I
tried that you know you can fail a
thousand times it takes one big victory
as an entrepreneur to be considered a
very very keen to establish entrepreneur
you don't need to have all victors one
big victory
you know plummets thousands of failures
so don't worry about that you're not
looking to have all projects being big
second thing to be thinking about is
looking at everything when I think about
ideas and projects I think about bites
so look at it like this start middle
finish everything in your mind that you
want to do something is normally going
to have a one-two-three I either like
three steps or I like five steps there's
something magical about three steps or
five steps so why don't we do this too
we do this three we do this
start middle finish okay start middle
finish
so think about steps when you're
thinking about ideas and we'll cover
five steps here on exactly how we go
about projects and different ideas that
we have and then the next one is as
you're writing out your ideas or project
is being able to prioritize and know
like this is a great idea but this is
not a short-term idea this is a five
years from now this is a ten years from
that this is three years from now this
is a year from now this is six months
let's revisit this three months from now
and just setting it aside on a note you
can have a phone with a lot of ideas in
here you can have a idea folder to say
with all the ideas that you have which
everybody ought to have or a folder that
yeah they write all your ideas that's
private to you and then you revisit when
the times are so let me get right into
it there's five steps step number one
when it comes down to ideas is the
actual ideation phase okay that leads to
a project so let's explain yeah so you
get together with a mastermind and a
mastermind to me is a group of three to
five people the purpose of the
mastermind getting together is simply to
think out loud and process issues
together step number one is ideation
masterminding and processing with three
to five people what do you want to get
together with the ideas questions for
instance what's the next idea that we
can come out with that thinking can take
the business to the next level
hypothetically what's the next thing I
need to do to improve my brand what's
the next thing we need to do what can we
come up with to do what's the next thing
we can it's constant ideas that you're
coming up with right and as you're
sitting there the next question becomes
is out of all these five ideas which of
them has the highest ROI for the time
we're going to put into a rate of return
or a return on investment on the time
we're going to put into it so we got
these 20 ideas we came up with no
definitely no no no no okay this one's
going to be big this one's going to be
big which one's going to be big I think
this one let's look at this one in a
boom you spend time with that one right
during the part of ideation phase you
got to ask the questions on the return
and then also do we have the resources
for this idea somebody made salmon one
time we're in year one of starting PHP
financial for
and I rented this house in Lake Tahoe
it's the most expensive property rental
laked I was a nineteen thousand square
foot house it was cemented floors that
were heated ridiculous we had a great
time and I said ideas and won the guy
said I think we need to do a half-time
Super Bowl commercial and is a great
idea
I love the everybody's like it's great
idea how much does it cost three and a
half million guys we don't have three
and a half million to do a Super Bowl
commercial so one is the ideas and the
projects then it's the resources do we
have the resources for the ideas
sometimes you have ideation and somebody
could tell you the craziest thing and
say we need to go by Amazon it'll be
great okay we can't afford 70 you know
two hundred billion dollars to buy
Amazon so you need to know the resources
that we have as well okay then the
people who give me ideas and feedback
sometimes if I'm doing an ideation
meeting and somebody that's always
coming up with ideas and their
credibility for ideas is not that high I
don't give that much value for the ideas
sometimes a person that may not say a
lot but they say one thing but every
time they do it's that powerful it's
also knowing who to take ideas from
that's a very important thing to be
keeping in mind as you're doing that
another thing I do is I like to recruit
devil's advocates when I'm doing
ideation you know you always have
somebody that's very annoying that
always shuts down all ideas and if you
read the book inside the tornado you
will know what's he called the inside a
tornado directive pragmatic and then you
have the UH the complete opposite
pragmatic is the visionary type the idea
guy
but the pragmatic is always I don't know
what about this this this this this and
as much as you the idea person doesn't
want that person you need that person
steep could tell you you know many of my
friends in hey Pat what do you think
about us to decide that they'll come to
me okay
and I'll say have you thought about this
have you done this have you done have
you looked at this have you researchers
have you talked about have you talked
about this company this company or what
other companies are doing this what
other companies are doing this look at
their company I got a call from somebody
and says I want to start a detailed
Mobile Detailing business etc etc like
an uber type and now who's done it who
is that let's come we met in contact
with the CEO we'll met with a CEO it's a
former Italian guys we sat down with
them find out what they're doing how I
should
how many it's just finding that part out
and you're like well do we want to put
three million dollars you want to get
the roundest guys already around three
do we want to go compete with this is
this something you want to do are you
fully committed to this are you so then
you're getting into that part you need a
devil's advocate this is not a power of
positive thinking of having somebody sit
there and tell you oh awesome let's go
get it no no no that person I guess go
get it they're not putting the money if
the person that says yeah let's go do it
if they're willing to fund 100% yeah
let's go do it and if you're that
optimistic funded let's go do but if
you're not doing putting the money I
need somebody to tell me that's not
afraid to say I don't think this is a
good idea because of dot dot man I don't
like to shut down but he's right we move
on now if you firmly believe in that
idea I like a good argument I like that
man he's got a point nope you're right
let's get this idea right so you got to
be able to understand that part so first
thing gets ideation out at the end I'll
give you an example on how one would
look like ideation second thing is
initiation so it's five eyes will go
through ideation then initiation so
let's just say now you have an idea that
you like and you say we have the
resources this could be big we like the
ROI it could really help the company it
could really help the brand let's move
with this then it's initiation
so what's initiation the first things I
think about is who are the people that
can be involved in this project that can
help us out okay this person is going to
this that person's going to this is
person we make a list of names of people
so this person knows that person this
person worked over here this person did
this is person that you put names right
then do we do it ourselves
or do we outsource so do I go buy a
standalone of this and leverage this
software or do we go and design the
software ourselves and spend two and a
half three years and if you have read
the book inside the tornado they say if
you have to build or buy
I mean 99% of the time it's buy is what
it is and I know entrepreneurs want to
own everything no no we have to own it
we have to own it we have to own every
single thing look sometimes great
partnerships like if you look at
Facebook when they first got started
first first first they got started they
we're shopping Google and they were
shopping Microsoft there even a five
million dollar company at that time they
went and signed a big contract with uh
with with who the companies as a Google
they signed a big contract with Google
big contract with Google their revenues
doubled Microsoft was annoyed that
Facebook didn't then Facebook went and
signed the same exact contract with
Microsoft so now they have two partners
they didn't use the resources to design
what these guys already had they're
making a ton of the money because of
partnership but their vision is bigger
they leverage both companies Google and
Microsoft now they're competing with
them they're valued at 300 billion
dollar company so sometimes it's knowing
that do I have to go out and do this
myself or has somebody already done this
that I can go out and use that software
and then two three five ten years from
now if I need to buy the code I can ask
them to buy the co2 increases the value
of the company you may do that and if
not you don't need to do it because it
was not the worth what you thought it
was going to be when should added know
that in the earlier part so I know I'm
thinking fast and I'm speaking fast but
I hope you're tracking on what I'm
seeing here with that part who can i
leverage that stun this before
somebody's done it before and maybe it
didn't work for them it did work let's
initiate a contact with them and have a
meeting and have a call with them great
another one is if we do do this how long
will this take order to get done I'll go
a little bit more into the deadlines
later on baby how can we break it down
into handful of different processes that
we'll have if we do this okay if we're
doing a project that we want to go out
and come up with a software what's
number one number one we got to do this
number two we got to do this three four
five okay let's go one two three four
five let's start one then two then three
who's taking care of one who's taking
care to who's three who's for that they
need delegate responsibilities to them
on what they need to be doing right and
everyone has certain deadlines on the
responsibilities that are given to them
and then how do we ply the project when
it's finalized you're thinking okay when
the project's finalized what are we
going to do with it what kind of a place
can we use this ad who are we going to
launch it are we going to do this are we
going to you'll think about those in
this is purely initiation phase the next
phase is instruction which instruction
phases start the process by instructing
who does what you've already decided
you're doing this after the initiation
phase like we're doing this so we have
ideation excitement initiation guys I
think this is a series we're thinking
about doing this and what if we
this who can do that' denison guys we're
doing this we made a decision a week
with slow you know stuff down it took a
week we thought about it we cracked
every single thing that this is going to
work or it's not going to work we're
doing it instruction
here's breaking into different bytes
that's going to go this then it's going
to go this then you're processing the
whole thing to break into different
bytes and then you figured out here's
what we're doing we're moving forward
okay
responsibilities all given five is
inspection so now you have a product so
that's being billed so let's just say
it's being broken out to the five
different phases of developing software
one part is done like let's test it out
it's working okay great we're looking at
this we're inspecting it oh there's a
glitch what's this all about why did
that come up okay message why did that
come up message why did this come up and
so why when I did this it didn't send
the email that I was supposed to wasn't
doing this there's an issue here right
so it's constantly tracking and
advancing where you're at when you're
inspecting everything and is there's
constant accountability constant emails
we're here we're here this is what
happened this will right here and if you
have like a different set ups you can
use to know exactly who's working on
what different projects you can do that
as well and that's an implementation and
implement implementation at this time
you're doing a testing final testing and
execution but in the implementation
phase you may do a soft launch with
somebody small to use it beta testing
some call it soft launch whatever you
want to call it someone's going to test
innate in his element we were having
problems in this area okay great
we were having problems with this
circuit what we didn't know that okay
what have a proms in is okay no problem
as good we were have proms in this area
and then we fix it right and then after
the testing is done when you're
implementing then you launch it and then
you have a real meeting on how to launch
it so if it's a product you're selling
what are we going to be our price point
what's the sixty forty are we going 6040
split sales all this other stuff well
you're talking about launching are we
going to launch this product in the
market are we going to use a vendor how
to sell it that's a whole different
episode I'll do but your strategy is
more on the launching part of this
product that you have right so now
knowing that I went through a lot of
stuff fairly quickly
let's break one down together fair
enough let's just say you're sleeping
you wake up on Sunday and you say I want
to write a book okay I want to write
book you want to write a book I want to
write a book okay step number one is
what ideation so what's the first thing
you do you sit there and you grab a
sheet of paper and you start writing
title would be this know what about five
write about this no I can write about
this what am I an expert in I can write
about this and you have ideation with
your wife maybe maybe we are has been
maybe your boyfriend/girlfriend
maybe it's your best friend dad somebody
that works with you what do you think
should write to have you thought about
writing it on this have you thought
about writing it on that you always
thought what do I talk about the most
you always talk about this what do
people come to me for advice and you
always talk about the timing that's
great so now you have twenty different
ideas on books okay then you go and say
what's timely what should I write now
okay what is a good time your book right
now what is a book I shouldn't write
right now what is a book I haven't
earned the right to talk about yet I
know a lot about it but I haven't earned
the right to talk about it maybe you
want to write a book on dating or you
want to write a book on you know how to
become successful but you're not
successful you don't want to write that
book it doesn't make any sense for you
to write that book right I know a lot of
people do it we have a lot of books and
people that write book on how to be
successful in the most success they've
ever had is they've just been a
consultant they made a hundred grand a
year how to become a millionaire it just
doesn't make any sense the moment people
find out so you're at you're processing
that part on the ideation side great so
then you ask do I write this book now or
do I write this book later so out of the
twenty book titles you may say I love
these five book titles okay this one I'm
going to write five years from now this
one I'm going to write ten years from
now this one I'm going to write twenty
years from that this one I'm gonna write
a year from now this one I'm going to
write right now great okay number one
was ideation number two initiation okay
let's just say I want to write this book
let's just I want to write this book
what do I need okay I need a literary
agent that's going to help me with a
publisher so let me first see if the
idea is even good if I want to publish
it am I going to self publish am I going
to publish am I just going to do Kindle
how much is my price point Who am I
going to sell it through is going to be
an Amazon book is it going to be a
penguin book what am I going to do it
let me talk to somebody who's been there
before who can help me with the
publishing site so let me hire a
consultant I get on a internet I find
someone and I talk about writing a book
what do you think I should do sell
publisher this and they'll ask you how
many Facebook fans do you have you know
how many Twitter followers you have how
much is your following what's your
platform
if you were to come out with a book
right now how many people you know
automatically going to buy your book
every question they'll ask you is purely
business then you say I'm not going to
write a book then it's telling you are
not yet and implement a construction
phase right so your editor your digital
marketing agency your researcher this is
like you're putting the initiation if I
were to write the book I'm going to do
this instruction at this point you're
doing it you have decided you're going
to do this thing so you're going to
break down the books on how to write a
book okay let me write the book how do I
write a book one I already have my title
of the book okay now within the top for
instance let's just take the title the
book is how to become a great real
estate agent okay so then you have to
break down the chapters prospecting why
are you doing real estate marketing
branding yourself which size houses to
sell 250 to 500 thousand or half a
million and up or a million and up okay
do I partner with somebody who do I put
my real estate license with how much
money do I spend on advertising so then
you have your chapters so you make a
list of 10 20 30 40 50 chapters when you
do 50 chapters then you go from 50
chapters to 15 chapters because how to
do it's 50 chapters 35 belong within the
10 or 15 chapters okay then you have
that part then the next part you talk
about is stories what stories do you
have okay what stories can use stories
from other real estate agents you put it
in there right then you have quotes
you're going to use and you have
research that you're going to use to
validate how to real estate economy is
going to do realistic in the next 10
years and how it's a great time to be a
real estate agent
then articles to validate what you're
saying so that's instruction you're
already committed you're going to do
this number four is inspection you write
a chapter you send it to the editor you
reread looks good next chapter editor
really looks good then it's
implementation books done you have a
product you ask a handful of people that
you respect to read the book for you and
they say I like it I will change this I
don't like this part it was mistakes you
what about this then you have another
editing that you do then you have
another final editing that you do and
then you have a book so publish publish
or you go out there and do your
marketing how do you launch it do you do
soft-launched
who are your customers you're going to
target are you going to market that's
how you probably start the project so if
you take those five
processes aviation initiation
instruction instruction inspection then
implementation you will generally have a
system where you can use for any project
you're working on whether it's a
software whether it's a book whether
it's a new product whether it's a new
system whether it's whatever you want to
talk about that you're doing you can use
this exact system in any aspect of your
business to put together and come out
with a project that you're starting and
knowing which ones are not even worth
your time and how to actually finish
project and remember that one of the
biggest thing with projects are
deadlines when I say deadlines I like
everyone to have deadlines everybody has
deadlines and not one deadline many many
different deadlines and everyone has
many different deadlines including
yourself what do you guys need from you
by when so a big part of finishing
projects its deadlines and you've been
able to hold everybody accountable
including yourself to making sure that
project gets done so Steve you asked
forward a few other people did as well
but today we put into video and at this
point more you want to throw me my
favorite pillow here hey we have a goal
of getting 100,000 subs by August 31st
and I need your help I need you to help
us get there 200,000 subs we get a lot
of love for many of you that follow this
channel I need you to subscribe to this
channel if you haven't yet and get
everybody you know to subscribe to this
channel we believe we're the best
channel on YouTube for entrepreneurship
but we need a hundred thousand subs by
August 31st because I'm launching
something very very major in the next
couple months that you will know about
so if you haven't subscribed please do
so and if you watch this video in a
complete different website you can
always go to Patrick beta be calm boom
to see the video and subscribe to our
newsletter thanks for watching take care
everybody bye bye
you